okay let's start guys okay so I'll plan
for two days to catch up so you're a
little behind so it's okay so today I
want to talk about MVPs Markov decision
processes my finest to talk about that
for the first hour and then after that I
want to talk for ten minutes about the
previous lecture so remember like you
went over relaxation is kind of quick so
maybe we can go over that again and then
the last ten minutes I want to talk
about the project and and kind of the
plan for the project how you should
think about it this is coming up so we
should start talking about that so this
is an optimistic plan though
let's see how it goes what this is the
current plan okay all right so okay
let's get into it so Markov decision
processes so let's start with a question
let's actually do this just by hand so
don't need to go to the website so the
question is it's Friday night and you
want to go to Mountain View and you have
a bunch of options but what you want to
do is you want to get to Mountain View
with the least amount of time okay which
one of these modes of transportation
would you use like how many of you would
bike no one would like help of people
like how many of you would drive this is
this is popular mountain view would be
good Cal trainers some people would take
out rain sounds good uber and lyft we
have like a good like distribution why
yes yeah the good number of you go on a
flight as flying cars are becoming a
thing like this could be an option in
the future there are a lot of actually
startups working on flying cars but but
as you think about this problem like the
way you think about it is is there a
bunch of uncertainties in the world
right it's not a necessarily a search
problem right you could you could bike
and you can get a flat tire and you
don't really know that right you have to
like kind of take that into account if
you're driving there could be traffic if
you're taking the Caltrain there are all
sorts of delay with the Caltrain and
then all sorts of other uncertainties
that exist in the world and then you
need to think about those so it's not
just a pure research problem where you
pick your route and then you just go
with it right there are there things
that can happen and that can affect your
decision so and that kind of takes us to
Markov decision processes we talked
about search problems where everything
was at terminus
and now you're talking about this next
class of state basis functions which are
Markov decision processes and the idea
of it is you take actions but you might
not actually end up where you expect it
to because there's this nature around
you and there's this world around you
that's going to be uncertain and do
stuff that you didn't expect okay so so
so far we've talked about search
problems the idea of it is you start
with the state and then you take an
action and you deterministically end up
in a new state if you remember the
successor function successor of SN a
would always give us s Prime and we
would deterministically end up in s
prime so if you have like that graph up
there if you start in S and you decide
to take this action one you're going to
end up in a like there's no other option
that's how you're gonna end up in it
okay and the solution to these search
problems were these paths so we had the
sequence of actions because I know if I
take action one in action three in
action to I know like what is a path
that I'm going to end up hide and now
with the idea okay so when we think
about Markov decision processes that is
the setting where we have uncertainty in
the world and we need to take that into
account so so the idea of it is you
start this state you decide to take an
action but then you can randomly end up
in different states you can randomly end
up in s1 prime or ass to prime and again
because there is just so many other
things that are happening in the world
and you need to you need to worry about
that randomness and make decisions based
on that okay and and this actually comes
up pretty much like everywhere in every
application so this comes up in robotics
so for example if you have a robot that
wants to go and pick up an object you
decide on your strategy everything is
great but like when it comes to actually
moving the robot and getting the robot
to do the task like the actuators can
fail or you might have all sorts of
obstacles around you that you didn't
think about so there is uncertainty
about the environment or uncertainty
about your model like your actuators
that that you don't necessarily think
about and in reality they're affecting
your decisions and where you're ending
up at this comes up and other settings
like resource allocation so in resource
allocation maybe you're deciding what to
produce what is the product you would
want to produce and and that kind of
depends on what is the customer demand
and and you might not have a good model
of that and that's uncertain right it
really depends on what
products customers want and what they
don't and you might have a model but
it's not going to be like accurate and
and you need to do research allocation
under those assumptions of uncertainty
about the world similar thing is in
agriculture so for example you want to
decide what sort of what to plant but
but again you might not be sure about
the weather if it's gonna rain or if the
if the if the crops are going to yield
or not so there's a lot of uncertainty
in these decisions that we make and and
they make these problems to go beyond
search problems and become problems
where we have uncertainty and we need to
make decisions under uncertainty okay
all right so let's again another example
so this is a volcano crossing example so
so we have an island and you're on one
side of the island and what we want to
do so we're in that black square over
there and what we want to do is we want
to go from this black square to this
side of the island where we have the
scenic view and that's gonna give us a
lot of reward and happiness so so my
goal is to go from one side of the
island to the other side of the line but
the caveat is here is that there's a
small kano in the middle of the island
that I need to actually pass okay so and
and if I fall into okay now I'm going to
get a minus 50 reward more like minus
infinity but but for this example like
imagine you're getting a minus 50 reward
if you fall into the volcano okay so
alright so so if I have this thing here
on the side so if my slip probability is
zero which is I'm sure I'm not gonna
fall into it okay now should I cross the
island no oh yes well I should cross the
island and because I'm not gonna fall
right like I'm not gonna fall into that
minus 50 sleep probability is zero I'll
get to my twenty you reward everything
will be great okay but the thing is like
we've been talking about how the world
is stochastic and SU probability is not
going to be zero maybe maybe it is ten
percent so if there is ten percent
chance of falling into the volcano how
many of you would would still across the
island good number so the optimal
solution is actually shown by these
arrows here and yes the optimal solution
is still to cross the island like you're
you hear we're gonna talk about all
these terms but the value here is
basically the value you're gonna get at
that beginning like stage which is a
kind of well we'll talk about it it's
expected utility that you're gonna get
it's gonna go down cuz there is some
probability that you're gonna fall -
okay no but still like the best thing to
do is to cross the island
how about 20% how many of you would do
it with 20% so number of people it's
less still turns out that the optimal
strategy is to cross 30% one person so
with 30% that's actually the point that
you kind of you'd rather not not cross
because there's a soul okay no and it's
a large probability you could you could
fall into the okay and the value is
going to go down okay so these are the
types of problems you're gonna we're
gonna work with yes so two is like a
value the reward that you are going to
get that that state and then value you
compute that your propagated back you'll
talk about that in detail some on how to
compute the value okay
all right okay so that was just an
example so so that was an example of a
Markov decision process what we want to
do in this lecture is we are going to
like again model these types of systems
as Markov decision processes then we are
going to talk about inference type
algorithms so how do we do inference how
do we come up with this best strategy
path and in the middle I'm go talk about
policy valuation which is not an
inference algorithm but it's kind of a
step towards it and it's basically this
idea of if someone tells me this is a
policy can I evaluate how good it is and
we'll talk about value iteration which
tries to figure out what is the best
policy that I can take so that's a plan
for today then next lecture we are going
to talk about reinforcement learning
where we don't actually know what the
reward is and we don't know what the
what the transitions are so that's kind
of the learning part of a part of this
MDP lectures so Reid is going to
actually do the Duda lecture next nix on
Wednesday right okay so let's get into
let's get into Markov decision processes
so we have a bunch of examples
throughout this lecture so let's look at
another example so all right so actually
I do need volunteers for this so in this
example we have
two rounds and the idea is you can at
any point in time you can choose two
actions you can either stay or you can
quit okay if you decide to quit I'm
going to give you $10 actually I'm not
gonna give you $10 but imagine I'm gonna
give you $10 and then we'll end the game
okay and then if you decide to stay then
you're gonna get $4 and then I'll roll
the dice if I get one or two will end
the game otherwise you're going to
continue to the next round and you can
decide again okay so who wants to play
with this okay all right volunteer do
you want to stay or quit so that was
easy you got your $10 does anyone else
wanna play stay oh you got $8 sorry I
kind of get the idea here
right so you have these actions and then
with one of them like if you said to
quit you deterministically will get your
$10 and you're done with the other one
it's it's probabilistic and you kind of
want to see which one is better and what
would be the best policy to take in this
setting so we'll come back to this
question you'll formalize this and we'll
go over this so okay so then you need to
actually compute what is the expected
utility right so and that's what we want
to do right so so you might say oh I
want to I want to stay and then I get my
four dollars and I want to quit and then
I get 14 and maybe that is the way to go
that that could be a strategy but for
doing that right like we were going to
actually talk about that before doing
that we are going to define what would
be the optimal policy one other thing
that for this particular problem if
you're going to keep in mind is I'll
talk about in a minute you find a policy
but but the policy the way we define it
is it's a function of state so if you
decide to stay that is your policy if
you decide to not stay that is your
policy like you're not allowing
searching right now like as I talked
about this later in a lecture but I'll
come back to this problem okay so if you
if you decide that your policy the thing
you want to do is to just stay
keep staying this is the probability of
like the total rewards that you're gonna
get so you're gonna get four with some
probability and then if you're lucky
you're gonna get eight and then even if
you're luck here you're gonna get 12 and
if you're luckier you're gonna get 16
but but the probabilities are going to
come down pretty much like really
quickly so the thing we care about in
this setting is the expected utility
right an expectation like if I if I if I
run this if I average all these possible
paths that I can do what would be the
value that I get and for this particular
problem it turns out that an expectation
if you decide to stay you should get 12
so so you got really unlucky that you
got 8 but but in general in expectation
you should decide to stay yeah and then
we actually want to spend a little bit
of time in this lecture thinking about
how we get that 12 and then how to go
about computing this expected utility
and based on that how to decide what
policy to use right okay and then if you
decide to quit then then expected you
chose either it's kind of obvious right
because that you're quitting and that's
with probability one you're getting ten
dollars so you're just going to get ten
dollars and that is the expected utility
of creating so so when you when I said
when you roll a die I said if you get
one or two yeah you you say yeah and
then if you get the other so the 2/3 of
it you continue so so it's a 1/3 2/3
comes from there ok all right
I'll come back to this example this is
actually the running example throughout
this lecture so
what the lecture is about okay so let's
actually I do wonder finish it an hour
that's why maybe I'm rushing things a
little bit but we are going to talk
about this problem like throughout the
class so so don't worry about it if it's
not clear at the end of it we can
clarify things okay all right so I do
want to formalize this problem the way I
want to formalize this problem is using
an MDP so I want to I want to formalize
this at the MA as a Markov decision
process maybe I can just use this so in
Markov decision processes similar to
search problem so you're going to up
stakes so in this particular game I'm
going to have two states I'm either in
the game or I'm out of the game so I'm
in an end state where everything we
ended you're out of the game you're done
okay so so those are my states then when
I'm in these states
I'm in each of these states I can take
an action and if I'm in in-state I can
take 2 actions right I can either decide
to stay right or I can quit and if I if
I decide to stay from in-state that
takes me to something that I'm going to
call a chance node so a chance node is a
node that represents state an action so
it's not really like like the blue
things are my states but I'm creating
these chance nodes as a way of kind of
going through this example to see where
things are going so so did these blue
states are going to be my state I mean s
these chance nodes are overstating
actions so basically the snail tells me
that I started with in and I decided to
stay an attached node here basically
tells me that I started with in and I
decided to quit even though it's
deterministic me so I deterministically
go there but then from the chance node
that's where I'm introducing the
probabilities so from the chance node I
can like Todd was the clay end up in
there
different states in the case though it's
also deterministic in the case of the
quit in this case is deterministic yeah
so in the case of the quit we say 41 I'm
going to end up in this end state so I'm
gonna draw that with the note with the
edge that comes from my chance node and
I'm gonna save it by what if one I'm
going to get $10 and just be done okay
what if you're in this state this is
actually the state where interesting
things can happen with probability 2/3
I'm going to go back to in and get $4 or
which probability 1/3 I'm going to end
up an end and for $4 so so that is my
Markov decision process so so I had
maybe you can keep track of a list of
things we were defining in this lecture
so we just defined States and then we
said well we're gonna have these chance
nodes because from these chance nodes
probabilistic who you're going to come
out of them depending on what happens to
nature right and this is the decision
I've made
now nature kind of decides which one we
are going to end up at and and based on
that we move forward yeah all right so
so more formally we have a bunch of
things when we define an MVP similar
search problems like we now need to
define the same set of things so so we
have a set of states in this case my
states are in an end
ok we have a start state I'm starting
with in so that's my start state I have
actions as a function of States so when
I ask what are the actions of the state
my actions are going to be stay or quit
what are actions of end I don't have
anything and state doesn't have any
actions that come out of it and then we
have these transition probabilities so
transition probabilities more formally
take a state an action and a new state
so as a s Prime and tell me what is the
transition probability of that it's 1/3
in this case and then I have a reward
which tells me how much was that
rewarding
four dollars so so I'm defining so when
I'm defining my MDP kind of the new
things I'm defining is this transition
probability it shows me if you're in
state s and take action a and you end up
in s prime what is the probability of
that I'm an in I decide to stay and then
I end up in end what's the probability
of that that's one-third maybe I'm an in
I decide to quit I end up in end what's
the probability of that is equal to one
okay and then over the same state action
state crimes like next States we're
going to end up ad we were going to
define a reward which tells me how much
money did I get or like how how good was
that so it was four dollars in this case
or or if I decide to quit I got ten
dollars and if you remember in the case
of search problems you're talking about
cost I'm just flipping the sign here we
wanted to minimize cost here we want to
maximize the reward it's just a more
optimistic view of the world I guess so
so that is what the rewards are going to
be you find on you also have this is end
function which again similar to search
problems just checks if we are in an end
state or not and in addition to that we
have something that's called a discount
factor it's it's this value gamma you
choose between zero and one and I'll
talk about this later
don't worry about it right now but it's
a thing we define for our search problem
for our any piece all right so how do I
compare this with search again these
were the things that we had in a search
problem we had the successor function
that would deterministically take me to
s prime and we had this cost function I
would tell me what was the cost of being
in state s and taking action a so so the
major things that are changed is that
instead of a successor function
I have transition probabilities these
T's that that basically terminal was the
probability of starting in s taking
action a and ending up in s prime and
then the cost just became reward okay so
those are kind of the major differences
between search and MVP because things
are things are not deterministic
alright so that was the formalism now I
can define any any MVP model any Markov
decision process and then one thing just
one thing to point out is these
transition probabilities to see
basically specifies the probability of
ending up in in state s prime if you
take action a in state s so these are
probabilities right so so for example
you know like we have done this example
but let's just do it under on the slides
again if I'm in state in I take action
quit I end up an end what's the
probability of that one and then if I'm
stayed in I take action stay I end up in
state in again what's the probability of
that I ended up in in again two-thirds
and then if I'm stay in I take action
stay I end up in end it's probability of
that one third yeah and and these are
probabilities so what that means is they
need to kind of add up to one but one
thing to notice is well just what is
gonna add up to one like like all of the
things in the column are not gonna add
up to one
the thing that's going to add up to one
is if you consider all possible these
different X Prime's that you're going to
end up at those probabilities are gonna
add up to one so so if you look at this
table again if you look at deciding and
being stay in and taking actions stay
then the probabilities that we have for
difference s Prime's are two-thirds and
one-third and those two are the things
that are going to add up to one and in
the first case if you're in stay in and
you decide to quit then wherever
whatever else primes you're gonna end up
had in this case it's just the end State
those probabilities are gonna add up to
one so so more formally what that means
is if I'm summing over s primes these
new states that I'm going to end up at
the transition probabilities need to add
up to one because they're basically
probabilities that tell me what are the
what are the things that can happen if I
take an action yeah and then this
transition probabilities are going to be
non-negative because there are
probabilities so that's also another
property so
usual things alright so so that's a
search problem let's actually formalize
another search problem this is let's
actually try to code this up so what is
this search problem this is the
problem so remember the problem I
have blocks 1 through n what I want to
do is I have two possible actions I can
either walk from state s to state s plus
1 or I can take the magic tram that
takes me from state s to stay to s if I
walk that costs 1 minutes
okay means reward of that is minus 1 if
I if I take the tram that costs 2
minutes and that means that the reward
of that is minus 2 okay and then the
question was how like how do we want to
travel from from 1 to N in the least
amount of time so so nothing here is is
probable stick yet right so I'm gonna
add an extra thing here which says the
tram is going to fail with probability
0.5 so I'm gonna decide maybe to take a
trial at some point and that tram can
can fail with probability 0.5 if it
fails I end up in my state like I don't
go anywhere and and actually like in
this case you're assuming you're still
losing 2 minutes so if I decide to take
the tram I'm gonna lose 2 minutes
maybe you'll fail maybe you will not
okay all right so let's try to formalize
this so we're gonna take our tram
problem from two lectures ago so this is
from search one we're gonna just copy
that
so alright so this was what we had from
last time he had this transportation
problem and we had all these like
algorithms to solve the search problem
we don't really need them because we
have a new problem so it's just get rid
of them and now I just want to formalize
an MDP so it's a transportation MDP ok
the initialization looks ok start state
looks ok I'm starting from 1 is end
looks ok so the thing I'm going to
change is the first off I need to add
this actions function ok so what would
actions do it's going to return a list
of actions that are potential actions
and you give
State so I just copy-paste it stuff from
down there you just edit so it's going
to return a list of valid actions okay
so what are the valid actions I can take
I can either walk or I can tram so I'm
gonna remove all these extra things that
I had from before and just keep it to be
I'm either walking or I'm taking the
tram okay as long as it's a valid state
so so that looks right for actions the
only thing we had was a successor and
cost function so so now we want to just
change that and return these transition
probabilities and under wort so so it's
basically the successor probabilities
and reward okay so I'm putting those two
together similar to before we had
successor and cost now I'm returning
probabilities and rewards okay so so
what this function is going to return is
it's going to return this new state is s
Prime I'm going to end up at and the
probability value for that under a word
of that okay so so given that I'm
starting in state s and I'm taking
action a then what are the potential s
crimes that I can end up at and what are
the probabilities of that like then what
is T of si s Prime and what is the
reward of that what is the reward of si
s Prime I want have a function to just
return to these so I can call it later
okay
all right so I need to basically check
like for for each one of these actions I
can or for action walk what happens for
action walk what's new state I'm gonna
end up back well I'm gonna end up at s
plus one it's a deterministic action so
I'm gonna end up there with Parvati one
and what's the reward of that minus one
because it's one minute costs so it's
minus one report then for action tram we
kind of do the same thing but you have
two options here I can I can end up in
2's tram doesn't fail I end up into s
this probability 0.5 that cost that
reward of that is minus 2 or the other
option is I'm going to end up in state s
cuz I didn't go anywhere because we
probability point 5 to Tran
to fail and that cut that nerve world of
that is - - and that's pretty much it
that that is my my MVP so I can just
define this for a city with let's say
ten blocks oh and we need to have the
discount factor but we'll talk about
that later let's say it's just one for
now yeah and they'll use right I'm
writing this other states functions were
later but that look right just
formalized this MVP so let's check if it
does the right thing so maybe we want to
know what are the actions from state 3
what are the actions from state 3 oh we
need to remove this you to a function
from before because we don't have it in
the folder move that what are the
actions from state 3 I have 10 blocks if
I'm in state 3 I can either walk or tram
right or one of them is fine right so so
that did the right thing
maybe we want to just check if this
successor probability and your horde
function does the right thing so maybe
maybe we can try that out for state 3
and walk so so for step 3 and action
walk then what do we get well we end up
in 4 and that it that is with
probability 1 with the reward of minus 1
okay let's try that for tram again
remember tram can fail so I'm gonna get
two things here so these are the things
I'm gonna get it for tram I'm going to
either end up in 6 with probability 0.5
with the reward of minus 2 or I will not
go anywhere I'm still at 3 with
probability 0.5 and that is with the
reward of minus 2 okay all right so that
was just a tram problem and we formalize
it as an MDP again the reason it's an
MVP here is is that the tram can fail
with probability 0.5 so we added that in
let me define our transition function
and our problem and our reward function
okay all right everyone happy with how
we are defining MVPs yeah
okay pretty similar to search problems
except for now we have these
probabilities alright so so now I have
define an MVP that's great
the next question that in general we
would like to answer is to give a
solution right so there's a question so
the Markov part means that you just
depends also when you you just depend on
the state and this current state like a
wavy to find our state you remember our
state is sufficient for us to make
optimal decisions for the future so the
Markov part means that your Markov and
you only depends on the current state
and actions to end up in that probable
equally end up in the next next so yeah
so the interesting question who would
like to do is well we want to find a
solution I want to figure out what is
the optimal path to actually solve this
problem and again if you remember search
problems the solution to search problems
was just a sequence of action said
that's all I had like a sequence of
actions a path that was a solution and
the reason that was a good solution was
like everything was deterministic so I
could just give you the path and then
that was what you would fall but in the
case of MVPs the way we are defining a
solution is by using this notion of a
policy so a policy let me actually write
that here so so you've defined an MVP
but now I want to say well what is a
solution of an MVP a solution of an
Markov the same process is a policy PI
of s so and this policy basically goes
from States so it takes any state and it
tells me what is the part was a
potential action that I would get for
that state okay so the policy is a
function it's a mapping from each state
s in the set of all possible States to
to an action in the set of all possible
actions okay so in the case of volcano
crossing like I can have something like
this I can be in state 1 1 and then the
policy of that state could be going
south or I can be in state 2 1 and a
policy for that state is if this was a
search problem I would just give it path
I would just say go south and then go to
go east and go north right so so that
would be my solution but but again like
if
decide that well the policy at 1-1 is to
go south there is no reason for you to
end up at South right because this thing
this thing is probabilistic so the best
thing I can do is for every state just
tell you what is the best thing you can
do for that particular state and and
that's why we are defining a policy as
opposed to get giving like a full path
all right so policy is the thing you're
looking for and ideally I would like to
find this best policy that would just
give me the right solution but in order
to get there I want to spend a little
bit of time talking about how good a
policy would be so and that's kind of
this idea of evaluating a policy so so
in this middle section I don't want to
try to find a policy I just assume you
give me a policy and I can evaluate it
and tell you how good that is so so
that's the plan for the middle section
yeah all right everyone happy it so so
far all I've done is I've defined an MVP
which is very similar to a search
problem
it's just probabilistic okay so so how
would we evaluate a policy so if you
give me a policy which basically tells
me at every state s take some action
then that policy is going to generate a
random path right I can get multiple
random paths because nature behaves
differently and the world is uncertain
so I might get a bunch of random paths
and then those are all random variables
random paths sorry and then for each one
of those random paths I can I can define
a utility so so what is a utility
utility is just going to be the sum of
rewards that I'm going to get over that
path and I'm calling it as the discount
at some of the rewards remember that the
scouts will talk about that but but you
can't you can just count the future but
before now just assume it's just a sum
of rewards on that time okay so you took
the utility that you're going to get is
also going to be a random variable right
because if you think about a policy the
policy is going to generate a bunch of
random paths and and utility is just
going to be the sum of rewards of each
one of those so it's a random variable
so if you remember this example right so
I can I can basically have a path that
tells me starting in
and then stay and then that ends right
so so this is one random hat and for
this particular on your path throw what
is it so see I'm gonna get I'm just
gonna get four dollars that's one
possible thing that can happen if my if
my policy is to let's say stay like
there is no reason for for the game to
end right here right like I can have a
lot of different types of random path I
can have a situation where I'm staying
three times and an after that ending the
game and utility of that is twelve we
can have the situation where we have
stay stay and end that's the situation
it's all like we told you have eight and
so on so so you're getting all these
utilities for all these random paths so
so these utilities are also going to be
just random variables okay so I can't
really play your arm with the utility
that's not telling me anything you know
it's telling me something but
surrounding variable I can't optimize
that so instead we need to define
something that you can actually play
around with it and and that is this idea
of a value which is just an expected
utility so so the value of a policy is
the expected utility of that policy and
and that's not a random variable anymore
that's actually like a number and I can
I can compute that number I can compute
that number for every state and then
just play around with value particularly
all possible so the question is yeah so
when you say value of policy is a policy
basically telling me it's a policy
basically telling me what what is the
strategy for all possible states well
you're defining a policy has a function
of state right so and value the same
thing as a function of state I might ask
what is the value of being an in so the
value of being in in is is an following
and following policies stay is going to
be the value of following policies stay
from this particular state which is
expected utility of that which is which
is basically that twelve value there I
could ask it for about any other state
to so I can be in any other state and
then say well what's the value of that
and and when we do value iteration and
you actually need to compute this value
for all states to kind of have an idea
of how to get from one state
but way to being in state in yeah and
the policy given your state in taking
the action state yes yeah and that is
that is what 12 is okay and 12 like we
kind of empirically have seen it's 12
but we haven't like shown how to get 12
yet okay all right so um actually let me
write these my list of things so we
talked about the policy what else did we
talk about we talked about utility so
what is utility utility we said it's our
rewards so if I get like reward one then
I get reward - it's a discount that
someone rewards so I'm gonna use this
gamma which is that discount that I'll
talk about in a little bit times reward
2 plus gamma squared 2 times reward 3
and so on so utilities you give me a
random path and I just sum up the
rewards of that
imagine if gamma is 1 I'm just summing
up the rewards if gamma is not 1 on
something I'm looking at this discounted
song okay so so that is utility but
value so this is utility value is just
the expected utility okay so you give me
a bunch of random path I can compute
their utilities I can just sum them up
and average them and that gives me value
that's a very good question we'll get
back there so so so in general in okay
if it is a cyclic it is fine but if you
have a cyclic graph you want your yama
to be less than one and we will talk
about that when we get to the
convergence of all right okay all right
so so let's go to the this particular
volcano crossing example so in this case
like I can run this game and every time
I run it I'm gonna get a different
utility cuz like I'm gonna end up in
some random path some of them end up in
the volcano that's pretty bad right so I
get different utility values utilities
but the value which is expected utility
is not changing really it's just around
3.7 which is just the average of these
utilities so I can keep running this
getting the
different utilities but what value is
this one number that I can I can talk
about and that's the value of this
particular state and that tells me like
what would be the best policy that I can
take and what's the best amount of
utility that I can get from an
expectation from that state all right so
we've been talking about this utility
I've actually written that already on
the board so utility is going to be a
discounted somewhat rewards and then
we've been talking about this discount
factor and yeah yield of the discount
factor is I might like care about the
future differently from how much I care
about now so so for example if you give
me four dollars today and you give me
four dollars tomorrow look if that four
dollars tomorrow is the same kind of
amount and has the same value to me as
today then then I might it's kind of the
same idea of having a discount counter
of one account and discount of 1 gamma 1
so you're saving for the future the
values of things in the future is the
same amount if you give me 4 dollars now
if you give me four dollars 10 years
from now it's going to be 4 dollars I
care about it like with four dollars
amount and I can just add things up but
it could also be the case like you might
be in a situation in a particular MVP
where you don't care about the future as
much maybe you give me four dollars ten
years from now and that's that doesn't
like I don't have any value for that so
so then if that is the case and you just
want to live in the moment and you don't
care about the values you're gonna get
in the future then that's kind of the
other extreme when justice gamma this
discount is equal to zero so so that is
a situation that if I get four dollars
in the future that they don't like value
like I don't have any value to me
they're just like are zero to me so so I
only care about right now living in the
moment
what is them on I'm gonna get and in
reality you're like somewhere in between
right like we're not just this case
we're real living in a moment we're also
not this case that that everything is
just the same amounts like right now or
in the future like in balance life is a
setting where we have some discount
factor it's it's not zero it's not one
it actually discounts values in the
future because future maybe doesn't have
the same values now but but we still
value things and if
like four dollars still something in the
future and that's where we pick like a
gamma that's between zero and one so so
that is kind of a design choice like
depending on what problem you're in you
might want to choose a different gamma
it's not really an assessment of risk in
that way it depends on the problem it
depends on like in the particular
problem I do want to get values in the
future I have like some sort of
long-term like goal that I want to get
to and I care about the future like it
depends like if you're solving a game
versus you're solving like I don't know
like a robot manipulation problem like
it might just be very different like the
scale factors that you would use for a
lot of examples we would use in this
class you just choose a gamma that's
close to one like usually like four for
a lot of problems that we end up dealing
with gamma is like points nine that's
like the usual okay like for usual
problems like you might have a very
different problem and we don't care
about the future so so then we just drop
it
yes okay so that's a good question so it
is gamma a hyper parameter that you need
to tune I would say gamma is a design
choice it's not a hyper parameter
necessarily in that sense that oh I'll
pick the right gamma I will do the right
thing you would want to pick a gamma
that kind of works well with your
problem statement and then gamma of zero
is kind of young greedy like you were
picking like what is the best thing
right now and I just don't care about
the future ever
it doesn't really the Markov property
it's just a discount of like you know
it's about the reward it's not about how
this state affects the next state it's
basically affects how much reward you're
gonna get or how much do value reward in
the future it doesn't it doesn't
actually like it's still Markov decision
process what you're getting whether it's
affecting the reward yeah but it's more
called because the iphone's state s and
I take action a I'm gonna end up in s
Prime and that doesn't depend on like
gamma
all right so okay so so in this section
we've been talking about this idea of
someone comes in and gives me the policy
so the policy is PI and what I want to
do is I want to figure out what's the
value of that policy and again value is
just expected utility
okay so V PI of s is just six but a
utility received by following this
policy PI from state yes okay so so I'm
not doing anything fancy I'm not even
trying to figure out what PI is all I
want to do is I want to just evaluate if
you tell me this is PI how good is that
what's the value of that okay so so
that's what a value function is so value
of a policy is V PI of s okay that's
expected utility of starting in some
state let me put this here yeah so we PI
is the value of the expected utility of
me starting in some state us okay and
state s has value of PI of s and if
phones tells me that well you're
following policy PI then I already know
from state s the action I'm gonna take
is PI of s so that's very clear so I'll
take PI of s and if I take PI of s well
I'm going to end up in some chance nope
okay and that chance note is a state
action note it's going to be s and the
action I've decided the action is PI of
s I have this define this new function
this Q function Q PI of Si which is just
the expected utility from the chance
node okay so so we've talked about value
values expected utility from my actual
States I'm gonna talk about Q values as
expected utilities from the chance notes
so after you have committed that you
have taken action a and then your
following policy PI then what is the
expected utility from that point on okay
and well what does the expected utility
from
point on we are in a chance note so many
things that can happen because I have
like nature is going to play Andros die
and anything can happen and they're
gonna happen with transition s a s Prime
and with that transition probability I'm
going to end up in a new state I'm gonna
call that s Prime and the value of that
state again expected utility of that
state is V PI of s prime all right
so okay so what are these actually equal
to so I've just defined value as
expected utility Q value as expected
utility from a chance node what are they
actually equal to okay so I'm gonna
write a recurrence that you're gonna use
for the rest of the class so pay
attention for five seconds there's
question day so they're both of them are
expected value yeah just one is just a
function off state the other one you've
committed to one action and the reason
I'm defining both of them is to just
writing my recurrence it's gonna be a
little bit easier because I have this
state action note and I can talk about
them and I can talk about pal but if I
get branching from these state action
notes okay all right so I'm gonna write
a recurrence it's not hard but it's kind
of the basis of the next like n lectures
so pay attention so alright so V PI of s
what is that equal to well that is going
to be equal to zero if I'm in an end
state so if is end of s is equal to true
then there is no expected utility that's
equal to zero that's an easy case
otherwise
well I took policy is someone told me
take policy is so value is just equal to
Q right so so in this case we PI of s if
someone comes and gives me policy hi
it's just equal to Q PI of s these two
are just equal to each other so the next
question one might ask is actually let
me write this a little closer so I'll
have some space
so this is equal to Q PI of s so so what
is that equal to what is Q PI of Si
equal to this is via this so now I just
want to know what is Q value key PI of
si what is that equal to
okay so if I'm right here then there are
a bunch of different things that can
happen right and I can end up in these
different s Prime so if I'm looking for
the expected utility then I'm looking
for the probability of me ending up in
this state times the utility of this
state plus the probability of we ending
a new state times they told you of that
so so that is just equal to sum over all
possible s crimes that I can end up at
of transition probabilities of Si s
prime transition probability of ending
of a new state times the immediate
reward that I'm gonna get reward of si s
prime plus the value here what I care
about the discounted value so I'm gonna
add gamma V PI of s prime because I'm
talking about this this next state okay
is this serious okay so this is the
recurrence that we were doing in policy
evaluation again remember someone came
and gave me policy PI so I'm writing
this policy PI here someone gave me
policy PI I just want to know how good
policy PI is I can do that by computing
V PI what is reply equal to someone told
me it's your following policy PI so it's
got to be equal to just Q PI what is Q
PI equal to it's just sum of all the
like the expectation of all the places
that I can end up at that sum over s
primes transition probabilities of
ending up in s prime times the reward
the total reward you are getting which
is the immediate reward Plus this
counting in my future okay
and then following policy Pike I'm
starting from the master plan yes sir
you promised all right so okay so far so
good so so that is how I can evaluate
this policy right so so I have these two
recurrences if I have these two
recurrences I can just replace this guy
here and let's imagine we are in the
case maybe I can use a different color
up here I'm just replacing I'm just
replacing this guy right here I don't
know if it's worth writing it imagine we
are not in an end state if you're not in
an in the end of state then we PI of s
or what is that equal to
that is just equal to sum of transition
probabilities si s prime over s Prime's
times immediate reward that I'm gonna
get plus discounting V PI of s Prime
okay so this is kind of a recurrence
that I have I literally just combined
these two and wrote it in green if
you're not in an end state so if you're
not in an end State
this is the recurrence I have I have a
PI here I have a PI on this side too
so that is nice and and that is kind of
the the Placer I can compute V PI maybe
I can do it iteratively or maybe I can
actually find a closed form solution for
some problems but that is basically what
I'm gonna do I have V PI as a function
that depends on V PI of s prime and I
can just solve for this V PI okay it
allows me to evaluate policy PI I
haven't figured out a new policy all I
have done is evaluating what's a value
of pi okay all right okay so let's go
back to this example so let's say that
someone comes in and tells me about the
policy you got to follow is is stay so
my policy is to stay okay I want to know
I want to just evaluate that I want your
policy evaluation when you're doing
policy evaluation you got to compute
that V PI for all states so let's start
with v pi up end well that is equal to 0
because we know V PI at the end state is
just equal to 0
now I want to know what's V PI of in
okay state in what is that equal to
that's just equal to Q PI of in and stay
right v pi is just equal to Q PI in
mistake so I'm going to replace that
that's just equal to 1/3 times immediate
rewards which is for cost value of the
next state I'm going to end up at which
is end in this case plus 2/3 times the
immediate reward I'm going to get which
is 4 dollars plus value of the state I'm
going to end up at which is in okay so
so that is just that sum that we have
there right the PI of end is 0 so let me
just put that 0 there I'm gonna put 0
there I only have one state here to
write so that I just have this as a
function of this one state in so having
an equation I can find the closed form
solution of the PI of n I'm just going
to move things around a little bit and
then I'll find out that V PI of in is
just equal to 12 so so that's how you
get that 12 that I've been talking about
so you just found out that if you tell
me the policy to follow stay if that is
the policy then the value of that policy
from state in is equal to 12 yeah so so
the policy is a function of state I only
have this one state that's interesting
here right that that's on one state is
in so I need to win and when I define my
policy I need to kind of choose the same
policy for that stage right my policy
says and in you got either stay or you
got either quick quit all right so you
can basically do the same thing using an
iterative algorithm to so so here like
in the previous example it was kind of
simple I just solved the closed form
solution but in reality like you might
have different states and then in with
the company it might be a little bit
more complicated so we can actually have
an iterative algorithm that allows us to
find these meat pies so the way we do
that is we start with the values for all
states to be equal to 0 and this 0 I put
here is the first iteration so I'm going
to
my iterations here so so I'm gonna just
initialize all the values for all states
to just be equal to zero okay then I'm
just gonna iterate for some number of
time whatever number I care like I would
like to then what I'm gonna do is for
every state again remember the value
needs to be computed for every state so
for every state I'm gonna update my
value by the same equation that I have
on the board okay and the same equation
depends on the value at the previous
time step so this is just an iterative
algorithm that allows me to compute new
values based on previous values that I
have had and I served it like everything
zero and then I keep updating values of
all states and they keep going so
basically that equation but think of it
as like an iterative update every round
so you don't you run this for multiple
rounds every round you just update your
value okay so like here is just a
pictorial you're looking at it imagine
you have like five states here you
initialize all of them to be equal to
zero the first round you're going to get
some value are going to update it and
then you're going to keep running this
and then eventually you can kind of see
that the last two columns are kind of
close to each other and you have
converged to the true value so so you
again someone comes and gives you the
policy you start with values equal to
zero for all the states and then you
just update it based on your previous
value yeah so how long should we run
this well we have a heuristic to kind of
figure out how long we should run this
particular algorithm one thing you can
do is you can kind of keep track of the
difference between your value at the
previous time step versus this time step
so so if the difference is below some
threshold you can kind of call it call
it done and then say well I've found the
right values and then in this case we
were basically looking at the difference
between value at iteration T versus
value I generation t minus 1 and then
we're taking the max of that over all
possible states because I want the
values to be close for all states
is this gear so so I'm going to talk
about the convergence then you talk
about the gamma factor and and the
discount factor and basically City and
also how long you should run this to get
these is also a difficult problem and it
depends on the properties of your MVP so
if you have an ergodic if you have an
hour guard again between this is just
should work okay but in general it's a
hard problem to answer for general
Markov decision problem processes and
another thing to notice here is I'm not
storing that whole table like the only
thing I'm storing is the last two
columns of this table because because
that's the PI at iteration T and V PI I
generation t minus 1 those are like the
only things I'm storing because that
allows me to compute if I have
conversion that kind of allows me to
keep going because I only need my
previous values to update my values
right in terms of complexity but this is
going to take order of T times s times s
prime well why is that because I'm
iterating over T time steps and I'm
iterating over all my states and I'm
summing over all s Prime's so because of
that that's a complexity I yet and one
thing to notice here is it doesn't
depend on actions it doesn't depend on
the size of actions and the reason it
doesn't depend on the size of actions is
you have given me the policy you're
telling me follow this policy so if
you've given me the policy then I don't
really need to worry about like the
number of actions I have okay all right
here is just another like the same
example that we have seen so at
iteration T equal to 1 n is going to get
4 and it's going to get 0 Ida duration 2
it gets a slightly better value and then
finally like a duration like 100 let's
say we get the value 12 and remember for
this particular example like this
example we were able to solve it like
solve the closed form we have v of
policy staying
from state n but but you could also run
the iterative algorithm and get the same
value of 12
the number of actions is the size of s
Prime no because you the size of s you
might end up in very different different
states this depends on your
probabilities the size of X prime is
actually the size of like size of states
is the same thing like it's the worst
case scenario you're going from every
state to every state just imagine that
size of s okay oh it's the summary so
far where are we so we have talked about
MVPs these are graphs with States and
chance notes and transition
probabilities and rewards and we have
talked about policy as the solution to
an MVP which is this function that takes
a state and gives us an action okay we
talked about value of a policy so value
of a policy is the expected utility of
that policy so so if you talk about
utility like you have these random
values before all these random paths
that you're gonna get for every policy
the value of utility is just an
expectation over all those random random
variables and so far we've talked about
this idea of policy evaluation which is
just an iterative algorithm to compute
what's the value of a state if you give
me some policy like how good is that
policy what's the value I'm gonna get at
every state all right so that has been
all assuming you give me the policy now
the thing I want to spend a little bit
of time on is figuring out how to find
that policy here we only have a stay or
quit if you have a different problem
that they can learn another actually
state way or something trade is going to
change the value of the policy
because then you have a new action and
then you need to update our policies so
in this case so far I'm assuming that
the set of actions is fixed I'm not like
adding new actions right like the way
even with search problems like the way
we defined search problems or the way we
are defining MVPs is I am saying like
I'm starting with a set up where states
are fixed actions are fixed I have stay
and create those are like the only
actions I can take the reward is fixed
transition probabilities are fixed under
that scenario then what is the best the
best policy I can take and best policy
is just from those set up like they've
already defined actions okay next
lecture we will talk about unknown
settings like when we have transition
probabilities that are not known or
reward functions that are not known and
how we go about learning them and that
would be the reinforcement learning
lecture so next lecture might address
some okay all right so let's talk about
value iteration so so that was public
evaluation so like that whole thing was
evaluation so now what I would like to
do is I want to try to get the maximum
expected utility and find the set of
policies that gets me the maximum
expected utility okay so to do that I'm
gonna define this thing that's called an
optimal value so instead of value have a
particular policy I just want to be
optimist which is the maximum value
attained by any policy so so you might
have a bunch of different policies I
just want that policy that maximizes the
value okay so and that is the Optus so
um so let me go back to this to this
example so I'm gonna have this in
parallel to this example of policy
evaluation I want to do value iteration
okay so I'm gonna start from state s
again state s has V opt
s okay that is what I would like to find
here I had V Pyrus if I'm looking for we
opt of s then I can have multiple
actions that can come out of here and I
don't know which one to take but like
any of if I take any of them if I take
this guy that takes me to a chance note
of si okay and then I'm looking for Q
opt of si
and from here it's actually pretty
similar to what we had right here so I'm
in a chance note anything can happen
right nature plays and with some
transition probability of a prime I'm
going to end up in some new state and
its prime and I care about the opt of
that so if I'm looking for this optimal
policy which comes from this optimal
value then I need to find V opt and if I
want to find V opt well that depends on
what action I'm taking here but let's
say I take one of these and if I take
one of these I end up in a chance note I
have Q opt of the saying that chance
note and then from that point on with
whatever probabilities I can end up in
some s prime okay so I want to write the
recurrence for this guy similar to the
recurrence that we wrote here it's gonna
be actually very similar so okay so I'm
going to start with you because that is
easier so what is Q opt of si that just
seems very similar to this previous case
what is that equal to what was q pi q pi
was just some of transition
probabilities times rewards right so so
what is Q opt yeah so so it would just
be basically this equation except for
I'm gonna replace me pi we'd be opt so
so from Q opt I can end up anywhere like
based on the transition probabilities so
I'm going to sum up over s Prime's and
all possible places that I can end up at
I'm gonna get an immediate reward which
is RSA s Prime and I'm gonna discount
the future but the value of the future
is V opt of s prime okay so so far so
good that's Q opt how about we opt what
is that equal to well it's going to be
equal to zero if you're in an end state
that's similar to before so if his end
of S is true then ten eight is zero
otherwise I have I have a bunch of
options here right I can take any of
these actions and I can get any Q opt so
reach one should I pick which Q opt
should I pick the one that maximizes
right which actually I should pick an
action from the set of actions of that
state that maximizes q opt so so the
only thing that has changed here is
before someone told me what the policy
is I just took the cue of that here I'm
just picking the maximum value of Q and
that actually tells me what action to
pick so what is the optimal policy what
should be the optimal policy I'm gonna
call it high opt is what is that equal
to
it's got to be the thing that maximizes
V right which is the thing that
maximizes this this Q so because that
gives me the action so it's going to be
the argument of Q opt of SN a where a is
in actions okay all right so this one is
policy evaluation someone gave me the
policy with that policy I was able to
compute V I was able to compute Q I was
able to write this recurrence then I had
an iterative algorithm to do things this
is called value iteration this is to
find the right policy iteration this is
to find the policy how do I do that well
I have a value that's for the optimal
optimal value that I can get and it's
going to be maximum over all possible
actions I can take of the Q values and Q
values is similar to before so I have
this recurrence now and then the optimal
policy is just a narc max of Q
tiny far exactly like this to eight oh
yeah so you could get to ace it so the
question is yeah like what if like I
have to ace that give me the same thing
I can return any of them it depends on
your implementation of Mac's so you can
return any of them you're five minutes
over and be p1 okay so good news is the
slice are the same things that I have on
the board so so Q opt is just equal to
the sum that we've talked about V opt I
just add the max on top of Q opt same
story okay and then if I want the policy
then I just do the arc max of Q opt and
that gives me the policy right I can
have an again an iterative algorithm
that does the same thing it's actually
quite similar to the iterative algorithm
for policy evaluation I just start
setting everything to equal to zero I
iterate for some number of times I go
over all possible states and then I just
update my value based on this new
recurrence that has a max so very
similar to before I just do this update
one thing is the time complexity is
going to be order of T times s times a
times s fine because now I have this max
value over all possible actions so I'm
actually iterating over all possible
actions versus in policy evaluations I
didn't have a chriskiss someone would
give me the policy I didn't need to
worry about this all right so so let's
look at coding this up real quick okay
so we have this MVP problem we define it
it was a tram problem it was
probabilistic everything about it was
great so now I just want to do an
algorithm section an inference section
where I code up value duration and I can
call a value duration on this MVP
problem to get the best optimal policy
okay so I'm going to call value
iteration later all right
so we initialize so all the values are
going to become I might skip things to
make this faster so we're gonna
initialize all the values to just zero
right because all these values are going
to be 0 so I defined a state's function
so I for all of those the value is just
going to be equal to 0
so let's initialize with that then
you're just gonna iterate or some number
of time and what we want to do is you
want to compute this new value given old
values so it's an iterative algorithm we
have old values you just update new
values based on them so what should that
be equal to so we iterate over our
state's if you're in an end state then
what is value equal to 0 right if you're
not in an end state then you're just
gonna do that it that that recurrence
there okay so new value of a state is
going to be equal to max of what the Q
values okay so new V is just max of Q's
of states and actions okay so now I need
to define Q what does Q do here of state
an action is just equal to that sum over
/ s Prime's so it's gonna return sum and
it's gonna return sum over s Prime's
I define this successor probability and
report function that gives me new state
probability and rewards so I'm gonna
iterate over that and then call that up
here so given that I have a state in
action I can get new state probability
and report what are we summing you're
summing the probability the transition
probabilities times the immediate reward
which is reward here times my costs my
discount times my V which is the old
value of V over s prime over my new
state so that is my cue that is my V and
that's pretty much done we just need to
check for a convergence to check for
convergence we
kind of do the same thing as before we
check if value of V and new V are close
enough to each other that we can't call
it done I'm gonna skip these parts so
you can basically check if V minus nu V
are within some threshold for for all
states and if they are then V is equal
to nu V we need to read the policy so
policy is just arc max of Q so I'm gonna
make this a little faster so the policy
is just going to be well none if you're
in an end state and otherwise it's just
going to be arc max of our Q values so
I'm just writing Arg max here pretty
much I'm just returning the action that
maximizes the Q and then we need to
spend a bunch of time getting the
printing working so let me actually get
yeah okay all right actually right here
so I'm running this function I'm rich
I'm I'm writing out actually these are a
little shifted weird States values and
then PI which is the policy okay so it
starts off walk walk walk remember this
is the case where we have 50 percent
probability of tram failing and with 50
percent probability of translating these
are the values we were gonna get and the
policies still walk until state five and
then take the tram from from state five
okay which is kind of interesting
because the policy of the search problem
was the same thing too okay so the thing
we can do is we can actually let me move
this little bit forward we can actually
define this failed probability which
becomes just a variable so you can play
around with this if you pick different
fail probabilities you're gonna get
different policies so for example if you
pick a failed probability that is large
then probably like the policy is going
to be just just walk and never take the
tram because the tram is failing all the
time but if you decide to take a failed
probability that's close to zero then
then this is your optimal policy which
is close to the search problem so it's
basically the solution to the search
problem so
play around with this the code is online
this was just value duration value
duration and use on this problem
okay so I'm gonna skip this one too
alright so yeah and then this is also
showing like how over multiple
iterations you can kind of get to the
get to the optimal optimal value and
optimal policy using value duration so
in one iterations it hasn't seen it yet
so it thinks that the value the optimal
value is 1.85 it hasn't updated the
values and so like it I don't three
iterations it gets better but it hasn't
still updated it still thinks it can't
get to the other side and remember this
is a split probability of 10% but if I
get to like I think 10 then it
eventually learns the best policy is to
get to 20 and the value is 13 point 68
and if you go even like higher
iterations after that point it's just
fine-tuning so the values are around 13
so you can play around you the okay no
problem okay so when does this converge
so if your discount factor is less than
1 or your MVP graph is a cyclic then
this is going to converge so if MVP
graph is a cyclic that's kind of obvious
you're just doing dynamic programming
over your full thing so so that's going
to that's going to convert if you have
cycles you you want your your discount
to be less than 1 because if your if you
have cycles and your discount is let's
say 1 and let's say you're getting zero
rewards from then you're never going to
change
you're never going to move you move from
your state you're always going to be
stuck in your state and if you have
nonzero rewards you're going to get this
unbounded reward and keep going because
you have cycles and and it's just going
to end up becoming numerically so so
just a good rule of thumb is pick a
gamma that's less than 1 then then you
kind of get this convergence property ok
all right
so yeah summary so far is we have mdps
now we've talked about finding policies
rather than paths
policy evaluation is just a way of
computing like how good a policy is and
the reason I talk about policy
evaluation is there's this other
algorithm called policy iteration which
uses policy evaluation and we didn't
discuss that in the class but it's kind
of like a quick not equivalent but you
could use it in a similar manner as
value iteration it has its pros and cons
and so policy evaluation U is used in
those settings do not leave please we
have more stuff to cover we have value
iteration which computes this optimal
value which is the maximum expected
utility okay and next time you're going
to talk about reinforcement learning and
that's gonna be awesome so talk about
unknown rewards alright so that was MVPs
doing inference and and kind of defining
them I'm going back to the last lecture
just to kind of talk about some of the
stuff that we didn't cover last time
okay all right so if you remember last
night we were talking about search
problems so big future search problems
where we don't have probabilities and we
talked about a store as a way of just
making things faster and we talked about
this idea of relaxations which was a way
of finding good heuristics so a store
had this heuristic heuristic was an
estimate of future cost we wanted to
figure out how to find these heuristics
like how do we go about finding this
heuristic and one idea was just to relax
everything that allows you to come up
with an easier search problem or just
easier problem and that helps you to
find what the heuristic is okay so so we
talked about this idea of removing
constraints and when you remove
constraints then you can end up in nice
situations like in some settings you
have a closed form solution in some
other settings you have just an easier
search problem and you can solve that
and in some other settings you have like
independent sell problems so when you
remove constraints then then you have
this easier problem you can solve that
easier problem and that gives you a
heuristic you're not done yet
right you're you have a heuristic you
take that heuristic and then change your
costs and and just run uniform cost
search on your original problem so so
solving an easier problem is like you're
not done when you're solve the easy a
problem it just helps you to find the
thing that helps for the origin
problem so it's kind of like a
multi-step thing so examples of that is
if you have walls remove all the walls
you have an easier problem if you solve
that easier problem that gives you a
heuristic and in this case it's like
when you knock down these walls that
easier problem you have a closed-form
solution for it you don't need to do
anything fancy you don't need to do
uniform cost search any of that you just
compute them in height and distance and
and that gives you a heuristic with that
heuristic you go and solve your original
problem that was one example another
example is when you remove constraints
you have an easier search problem so you
don't have closed form solutions but you
have an easier search problem so you
might have a really difficult search
problem with a bunch of constraints that
are hard to do remove the constraints so
when you remove the constraints you have
a relaxed problem which is just the
original problem without the constraint
that's a search problem you can solve
that search problem using uniform cost
search or dynamic programming and and
solving that allows you to find the
heuristic again you're not done yet
right you take the heuristic and then
you go to the original problem change
the cost and I'm drawing uniform hazard
and just one quick kind of example here
was when you're computing these relaxed
problems the thing you want to find is
the future costs of this this relaxed
problem and to do that you have this
easier search problem you still need to
run uniform cost search or dynamic
programming in this case if you decide
to run uniform cost search remember
uniform cost search computes past cost
in this case I really want to compute
future costs so you need to do a bunch
of engineering to get that working in
this particular case the relaxed problem
you need to reverse it because when you
reverse it past cost of the reversed
relaxed problem becomes future cost of
the relaxed problem if that makes sense
so so the way I'm reversing this is I'm
basically saying start to stay this N
and state is 1 and my walk action takes
me to s minus 1 instead of s plus 1 and
my Tran action takes me to s over 2
instead of s times 2 and the whole
reason I'm doing that is is that the
past cost of this new problem is the
future cost of the non reversed version
ok because I need to use uniform cost
search here so I run my uniform cost
search that gives me a heuristic
and that heuristic gives me this future
cost of the relaxed problem and
everything will be great
another example is I can have
independent sub problems using my new
RipStik so in this case like they have
these tiles they technically cannot
overlap instead what we are allowing is
you're allowing them to overlap so if
they allow them to overlap I have eight
independent subproblems that I can solve
these sub problems give me heuristics
and I can just go with them okay so so
these were just a bunch of examples and
kind of the key idea was reducing edge
like when we are coming up with this
relaxed problems you're reducing edge
costs from infinity to some finite cost
okay so I'm getting rid of walls before
I couldn't cross like it was infinity
cost of that was infinity but if I get
rid of the wall I'm making it a finite
cost so this type of method this is a
general framework so the point I want to
make is generally you can talk about the
relaxation of a search problem so if you
have a search problem P a relaxation of
a search problem I'm gonna call that P R
ap R L is going to be a problem or the
cost of the relaxation for any state
action is less than or equal to cost of
state and action I'll take questions
afterwards all right so so that is a
relaxed problem okay so the cool thing
about that is if you're given a relaxed
problem then you can pick your heuristic
to be the future cost of the relaxed
problem and that is called the relaxed
heuristic okay so so this is kind of a
recipe a general framework like if
someone asks you find a good heuristic
find a relaxed problem future cost of
the relaxed problem is a heuristic and
the cool thing about that is it turns
out that that that that future cost of
the relaxed problem mature deciding to
be a heuristic is also consistent
because we talked about all these
consistency properties and and how you
want to find a heuristic to be
consistent for the solution to be
correct and how in the world am I going
to find a consistent heuristic well here
is one here is one way of finding
consistent heuristics pick your problem
make it relaxed making it relaxed means
that pick a cost that's less if we can
pick a relaxed problem where the cost is
less than the cost of the original
problem and then future cost of that
relaxed problem is just going to be your
heuristic and it's going to be
consistent so proof of that is two lines
skip that and and the quick think about
this like what knows about this is
there's a trade-off here there's a
trade-off between efficiency and
tightness so sure like making things
relaxed and removing constraints it's
kind of fun right you have this easier
problem and you just solve it and
everything is great about it but it's
not like there is kind of a trade-off
between how tight you want your
heuristic to be like you shouldn't
remove too many constraints because if
you remove too many constraints then
your heuristic is not a good estimate of
future cost
remember your heuristic is supposed to
be an estimate of future cost so so if
it is not a good estimate of future cost
and it's not tight then it's not that
great so so there is a balance between
how much you're removing you're
considering your constraints and and how
that makes finding the heuristic easier
versus the fact that you want your
heuristics to be tight and be close to
your future costs so so don't remove
everything leave some constraints and
then solve it and you can also do things
like if you have two heuristics that are
both consistent you can take the max of
that and you can take the max of that
it's a little bit more restrictive maybe
maybe that is closer to your future
costs and that is then you can actually
show the max of that is also consistent
okay so we talked about like relaxation
say a start what a quick thing I want to
mention because that wasn't very clear
last time it's structured this
perceptron we talked about that a little
bit too and we talked about convergence
of that so quick things on that
structured perceptron actually converges
there was this question that if we have
if that if you have a patch that is
let's say walk tram and and we end up
recovering another path that is tram
walk is that bad is that good well turns
out that the cost of both of these paths
are the same thing so if I end up
getting this path that's perfectly fine
to write like that that is also with the
same optimal weights in the example that
we have shown in a tram example I don't
think we are able to get two paths that
look like this because of the nature of
the example so so in general things to
remember from structures perceptron is
it does converge it does converge in a
way that it can recover the two Weiss
but it doesn't necessarily get the exact
double use as we saw last time right
like you might get two and four you
might get foreign air so guys as long as
you have the same
relationships that that is enough but
but you're going to be able to get to
actualize and it does convert so with
that project conversation is going to be
next time do take a look at do take a
look at the website so all the
information on the project is on the
website so you started thinking about it
look at the project page and that has
something